NARRATOR: See this?
This is a samurai, an
elite Japanese warrior.
And this is his sword,
his samurai sword.
Watch out!
It's super sharp.
They've been around for
over 1,000 years, as iconic
to Japanese culture
as cherry trees or Mt.
Fuji.
And thanks to, of all things,
a blacksmith, a potter,
and an ancient scroll, you
can still buy a totally 100%
custom-made katana blade today.
Seriously awesome.
So, random question--
how exactly
is this ancient knowledge of
making iconic Japanese samurai
swords still around?
Well, it's a pretty
incredible story
of ancient scrolls, fiery
forges, and the most
expensive steel on the planet.
Let's take a deeper look at
how the sword and the scroll
are linked.
The Shimane Prefecture in
Japan is wild with plunging
cliffs and volcanic islands.
It's full of sacred Shinto
shrines and waterfalls,
believed to bring victory
to bullfighters and sumo
wrestlers who drink its waters.
And sometimes, its rivers
run red, blood red.
But not with blood.
That's disgusting.
With iron deposits.
And that's how the blacksmith
made a living in this region.
He smelted that iron
into steel until he
and his buddy, the potter,
found an ancient scroll.
That taught them how to make--
drum roll please--
[drum roll]
--samurai swords.
Total job upgrade.
Nowadays, there are only about
200 traditional swordsmiths
left in Japan.
Shunji Kobayashi is one of
them, thanks to his grandfather,
the blacksmith.
So why is his
craft disappearing?
Never mind that society and
warfare have totally changed.
Making real swords
is a long process,
and they'll cost you
upwards of $25,000 a pop.
But remember those
iron deposits?
That iron sand is put into it
tatara, or a clay tub furnace.
This is the only
one left in Japan.
It's heated, mixed with charcoal
to add carbon, and voila!
Steel.
Tamahagane steel, the most
expensive steel in the world.
And that curved shape comes
from layering two kinds of steel
and submerging that red
hot, fresh from the forge
sword directly into the water.
Contracting metals
bend inward to form
that lethal, legendary blade.
And when you're holding one,
you're holding a millennium's
worth of trade secrets.
No pressure there, Shunji.
Shunji Kobayashi says it takes
six months just to make one
sword, and it takes five
years of training just
to polish a katana properly.
The whole swordsmithing thing
requires patience and attention
to detail, much like
the samurai themselves,
which is why the katana is known
as the soul of the samurai.
But that's not the whole story.
For more on the
sword and the scroll,
watch "Explorer" on
National Geographic.